ANNEXED FOUR RUSSIAN-OUPIED
TERRITORIES WITHIN UKRAINE
>> THE UR
GOING TO RECOGNIZE THIANQUITE FI
T EITHER.
EVFULLY PREPARED WTO DEFEND EVE.
SO MR.N'WHAT I'M SAYING.
EVIN.UNCINGCT
E
HEADRUALDAE
NNOUNCEMENT THE
RUSSIAN MINISTRY O
CNN' WALSH I THIS AL?
NGACCEPTANCE FROM MOSCOW THATHEE
OF STERN UKRAINE, THAEY HAVE
NOW EFD
AITTEHDR TROOPS.
WE DON'TW HOSFTHATS BEEN BECAUSE
SUES THOUSANDS WERE LEFT BE ENC
UKRAINIAN FORCES.
WHEN WE LISTE KREMLIN,
THEY TALK ABOUT ANNEXI
TEE INED AREASGHM
RALLIES IN MOSCOW AND THEN ON
THE GROUNDE REMARKABLES IN RUSSN
WHAT HAS BEEN ING, SINCE
THE NEWS
MISSION THEY
TRIED TOIT
IN FHTWI MOSCOELITE ON SOCIAL M
REPUBLICS OFSIA, HAS SHAMER NDI
PUTIN IS HNGF THIS
DISASTER ANDESTING THEY SHOULD
AREAS AND USLOW-YIELD NUCLEAR
WE
ABOUT WA H DISPLAYDION
O
TIMES RIDOUMB
IT FORMS WT UKRAINE ISSTILUTG
FRONT NE T
W METHODICAL
VANCE.
THE FALL O WRS
W
KNOC.
NGOU
LYMAN WHAT THE LEVELCITYIS UKRA.
UKINT BRAGGEMURKTHE OF DONETY RR
SUGGESTS THEY HAVE BEEN TO
Y  DHOW MUCH OF
DAAN IED UKRAI MCO
TERRITORY.
NG THETOF NO QUARTER G
ALL E H S  MN.
SPFOR THE WHOLE RESSING TWO S
SIX MONT O WARJU
E THR FEROCITY  FIGHTINAND ALSO,
E OF UKRAI'S AHIS TOWN ITSEL AT
IVED HERE R
SIX MONTHS AND  ITS NORMALI, ITD
IT IS THE MOSTHO RUSSIAINE PEOP.
DN'
SC WHEN THNSEFN  COURTYARD.
WA DOO AND TRIEDE EE SHUT BUT
A SOLDIER PULL
ME.  JUMPEWN AND FELL BASEMENT.
Rr: SOME SEEK SURVIVA
THY LOOK.
A
THEY MADE CH A MESS OF THEIR
BYHE JUNE.PRIEST, KILL
I ATTACHED IT AS A PROTEIV. HER?
THE C
D I HEARD IT, SHE YSANSTENED IM
Y TO LIVE.
ANXIOUS TO NOT SHOW THEIR FACES-
D INKE ME.
SHSTIM ALIVE P
THAT IL KNTHERE
USTU UKRAINE'SNCES.
ALL OF MOSCOW'S IMMINENT
ANNEXAE ABSURD CLAIM
NLLRUSSIATHE LANDERLLIOD  WER.
AN EXCEPTIONALLY TIME ITHFLICT.
RRITOR UAI THE MT
CONTROL
THE MILITARYVEG THEY
ELITE AMONGST
THEMSESOCIAL MEDIA.
THAT IS JUST NNG YOU
PUTIN'IS ALWS  HOMOGENOUS Q
NOW  BRIE
DOING THE GSSANO CLEAONARDEISINW
FOR THE RUSSN
FU